hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to bone works now bone works
is a game made by stress level zero
obviously a VR game but what makes this
game very special is not just that I
have individual fingers but that the
physics system in this game is so much
Souma dick Medina did you listen
addicted that there's a that's a good
example of it my backhand opened it but
there's a distinct representation of
physics in this game now I'm not
starting at the very beginning of the
game just because I actually got a
preview of this from Brandon who is the
developer on the game part of level 0 a
team of very talented people but I
played through the first area and what I
am eager to see is what the hell mana
GaN is what the Museum of technical
demonstration is and what the hell this
game has in store for me only one way to
find out oh myth os so there's something
the series going on with this virtual
world there was an intro there was an
intro segment of people going into VR
it's a whole VR world where everyone
comes together and if you die in here
maybe you die in real life I don't know
for a tool control instruction you know
what actually I don't even need to know
any of this because I know how this goes
or it won't let me through there because
those are blue barriers of very earnest
what about over here Wow
virtually stumbling around
[Music]
myth OS virtual that's hilarious
I'll just be on my way because I am the
very busy man with many busy things that
I need to do jumping got bullet time
apparently I don't think that's that
that's a thing I have okay so I got a
Crouch
[Music]
alright cool
so what am I gonna get to the meat of
the matter what am I gonna get to play
hoop miss me I can catch it
oh wow oh my god I love you
ride me haha I can imagine shooting some
cool people like this boss I want to go
again I want to go again it's just
walkable oh my god it is isn't it oh it
is climbable it's like a rock wall of
help ah this is like a v13 oh god what's
the full damage like ah nothing my knees
are stronger than God ladder
no it's pipes stupid whoever painted
that as a [ __ ]
alright you now got piped gurth yeah I'm
actually winded I probably shouldn't be
actually win it in real life but I feel
a little winded and then there's this
but it's the same principle it's borings
with
tutorial said it was gonna do oh I don't
get more what is this oh-oh-oh
[Music]
scuse me burn me boom-boom boom Herron
is my reward my reward we're even are
you guys like god damn it
ah nailed it
oh god damn it alright thrones a little
funky right at first anyway I'm gonna
I'm gonna get it though oh you're hefty
Oh what damn what the hell this game's
broken
oh this is good alright come on yeah
that actually feels good getting the
dick and the dick in the dick
oh god you weren't expecting me to
attack your dick move heavy objects
slowly if you physically imagine you're
holding heavy objects you will have an
easier time moving I am actually I've
actually come here you how are you
alright good beer you are you Big Bertha
crush me cross me okay I'm gonna get up
here
nailed it nail it really I'm going up
I'm gonna I'm going over yeah yeah okay
I want to go home ma ma help help
through here I guess oh man for a
tutorial that's her as interactive I'm
very tired already
okay exhibit under what base the what
model what what did you just say I
understood literally every word up until
the most important word that you were
saying at the end of the sentence so if
you could repeat that that's what
okay hmm
was that supposed to crush my dude here
barely not ah you can't be broken by
human means boom you are too strong this
is really impressive positive I don't
care what do we have here I could solve
this [ __ ] you think I don't know how to
wall oh oh
suddenly I'm on my own elevate emergency
elevator lock ah now whatever let's just
go up the damn thing oh come on oh okay
all right party yeah yeah yeah okay okay
okay okay
oh come on I'm up okay oh okay
huh Oh God up Oh mommy baby what's up
baby what's up please baby maybe needs
up baby needs up Oh God Oh got it okay
here lift one hand here one hand here up
up oh no okay maybe I'm not supposed to
do it that way huh let's go for we're
going there baby I gotta stop doing the
turning it's it's making me nauseous all
right we got this now this I can grab
there's some I feel like I got a hold up
oh oh my god I got scared I legitimately
got scared that was weird
okay I see what you're doing to me bone
works bony baby I see what you got okay
this is obviously not the correct way to
go about this but here we go all right
what do we got what do we get what are
we gonna up up eat up eat up eat up eat
up eat and droppy perfect stuck the
landing
no one better than me at this game
trouble jumping your height may be
calibrated incorrectly impossible
ha ha ha
never
ah got it oh [ __ ] wait Oh
oh god what what oh what oh oh oh what
did that do what that do I don't know
what that did hope yo yo I'm just gonna
stick to just turning cuz it feels
better and less nauseous doing ooh okay
oh yeah to early too early too early
it's okay
nailed it oh oh oh what did that just do
down there what the hell is that about
what did that do what are you doing down
there
alright fine whatever huh welcome to
floor 2 in the fog James you would learn
about various of advanced virtual
concepts you may find these exhibits
more complex and somewhat challenging
please take all the time you need in
order to fully grasp these mechanics we
recommend taking a short break oh I'm
completely backwards okay there we go we
recommend taking a short break then
return to these concepts when you feel
comfortable complete existence needs
foundation and meaning old myth well
myth or old truth what is this hahaha
Wow Oh
quick menu body slots ownership ooh
weird oh I don't like this we oh my god
what does this big button do oh oh wait
a minute wait a minute
there's another button over there that
there there there
why is my finger not pointing enough how
do you know that wait what the [ __ ] wait
my what the [ __ ]
are you guys seeing this look okay
finger my finger my finger is not
touching anything that it's touched the
button there what the [ __ ] okay these
have to touch to know that they're doing
anything but the finger how are you
doing that I don't understand that that
is super weird that is bizarre
okay I need some because I need to throw
who actually may be shooting a work pop
ow
where did that gun just go didn't I just
I just put it away somewhere where the
hell did that gun just go there oh
why is that not working oh I hit it
right in the dick you didn't expect me
to shoot you in the dick did you hello I
ejector oh I gotta pull it now I'm out
of ammo no oh I'm getting nauseous I'm
not gonna like like virtual reality has
come a long way but there still is the
nausea that comes because I don't do it
all the time ha ha ha larious okay let's
let's it let's get a move on I've seen
this this is all tutorial stuff I know
how this works I got it I got it baby I
got you oh yes please
ooh credits I don't have any credits
virtual geometry may not cross city
instances please recycled geometry and
the reclamation Bryn's all right I guess
whatever do I get a token for that do I
get anything aren't I supposed to get
some fat you said you were gonna give me
stuff and then you didn't oh whatever
let's go oh oh keep weapons playing in a
safe direction keep your finger off the
trigger until you're ready to bang bang
got it got it mister whoa whoa what is
this oh yes please yes please baby what
do we have here oh love it
[Music]
soozee yeah wait wait wait wait I gotta
get this in here oh man this is this is
actually complicated because it actually
requires you to like treat him like a
real gun would be treated in that you
have to actually press buttons and stuff
oh we a mist all right where's the
where's the cocking blocker there it is
oh yeah yeah my finger was on the
trigger things really got some kick to
it that's not bad
god the music is getting to me though
the music is literally grating on my
brain yeah I get it I get it I get it I
get it I get it
mm mm mm mm okay all dead though
perfectly acceptable here soon all right
you're dead let's see
oh you vandal taste my rapier greatsword
don't mind if I do
I am great after all that feels pretty
good all right cool let's get out here
hope oh whoa whoa whoa whoa wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute
314 wait a minute
yeah wait a minute wait a minute what's
going on here
I feel slightly nauseous but what's
going on here
ooh what the hell is this I got a key by
inserting this key you accept personal
responsibility for all risk to yourself
and others while inside the advanced
mechanics Hall the exhibits in this
falling chamber remember that complex
okay it's a gift shop no way come on
oh [ __ ] okay I swear there's more to
this game than just a technical
demonstration but as far as technical
demos go it's pretty damn cool
tom control big go love it oh I'm so
slow laughs okay so what's the what's
the point okay cool
oh I might throw up I might throw up I
might actually throw up ooh ooh I might
throw up okay all right guy oh okay I
got I got oh whoa oh whoa oh god I gotta
take a second to breathe oh my goodness
I want to keep going buddy man ooh boy
that is a bit of nausea a little bit of
mid mid Gabe intermission my thoughts
this is an incredibly well-made game so
far I haven't even gotten in the game
I'm still in the tutorial portion of it
it represents a lot of really
fascinating ways that VR could be good
but there's still the problem of
knowledge you know if I play VR every
day I'm sure I'd get used to it it
wouldn't get so nauseous inducing but
wowsie wowsa I might break hmm I just
need to oh I need to get solid ground
under my feet
I just need I'm fine yeah yeah yeah oh
my goodness
okay I feel good hole boy I feel I feel
great it's also the music like the
goddamn music is I might I might vomit
just from the music alone like it's it's
a cheerful track and all but God it's
just it's oh it's really getting to me
okay
go Beckett okay now I'm gonna get in
here I'm gonna show this game moves boss
and the boss is me and my God why are
you so [ __ ] loud holy [ __ ] - shut the
[ __ ] up I was so happy when it stopped
because I was like oh my god I break and
then something how different a couple of
with us to save goddamn beat over and
over again I like it it's great at all
but wolf okay gravity negative gravity
fields provide temporarily inverse mass
calculation for improbable lifts I agree
okay what is this okay this is a bubble
blower oh it's a balloon gun so I can
make something lift with enough balloons
right you need more than that you need
more than that you need more than that
come on I was wrong you oh oh yeah baby
how many balloons will it take to make
me fly really we're not doing it oh it's
just making them disappear you kidding
me I can't fly with this [ __ ] huh but I
bet I can die with this [ __ ] I'm not
careful huh um well boots now up will we
go oh oh did you find all the buttons in
the museum well I mean not really cuz I
wasn't looking for him I didn't know
that it was an objective well he's not
gonna hurt oh okay that's weird oh my
god Oh why do things go quiet now you
you you Oh
lovely why is it quiet now Oh cuz they
won't how do I fall alright it's
beautiful what happens if I get a helmet
on while I'm in the oho that's what
happens of a dig this up man what about
the vision same the perfect moment for
like there to put like a horror a horror
secret in here or something come on get
on my head there we go like something in
one of these fields standing in the
forest what who knows there might be oh
oh
that's vibrant and beautiful that's
lovely
perfect opportunity for a jump scare I'm
just seeing perfect opportunity all
right return to exhibits I'm not gonna
go back and get all the buttons just
because I really care all right let's
get out of here
yeah doors close at all times trash
handlers hello Oh what did i do what did
I do
was I supposed to do that ah God [ __ ]
cables was I supposed to do that I don't
know if I was supposed to do that I'll
get a drink oh my god oh [ __ ]
wait what's happening wait I'm not back
in yet wait God damns get off the
microphone ah God what hey wait what
happened I just need a sip let me I kick
rapidly gotten him controls oh yeah back
into it baby what's the deal what's
going on where am I
are you okay oh [ __ ] this looks bad
these corpses these corpuses these core
PI's these what you would call core
piece shoes okay sorry I just I made
some readjustments mid-game I don't know
why but yeah I did that okay here we go
right hey buddy how you doing nice ass
what's all this then why is this Brandon
particle waste why is there particle
waste why would there be particle waste
can I climb that I bet I can I've
totally bet I can yeah I can okay
god damn it okay that didn't work at all
Oh God okay fine I'll go up this way I
have no idea what the mechanics are for
jumping when I'm grabbing onto something
cuz it seems like I fall pretty good
it's almost like it's difficult to
actually climb like this okay can i oh
this is positionally strange alright
cool
good got that okay what are we doing
here what is the deal won't you god damn
you come on come on
ah there we go got it okay I don't know
what the purpose of this would be but
I've was taught one thing when I was in
VR school that's to climb in climbing is
what I'll do till the day I die give me
up on this thing
here we up on it I wanna pee come on
mark you want up ooh is that ammo I
don't know if it like getting up is a
thing you can actually oh no way no oh
God was what away
what the hell what the hell is that I'll
take that I guess oh god no please okay
well there was no point in that and I'm
not happy I did it why don't I hear why
is everyone dead what's the deal what's
up there is that a bell
ding-dong weird what is happening so is
the lore of this whole world like this
is some strange virtual world where
people choose to live ding ding ding
anybody home ding dong okay this is
pushing oh yeah
well that's great okay got more ammo do
I need ammo
am I gonna have to kill something oh I
love tetherball and just like my
childhood I've got no one to play with
this is building three five three two
five
hello you're alive you're depressed but
you're alive I think keep out I can't go
in there answer a little yellow oh whoa
whoa whoa hey hey oh whoa what are you
doing hey hey screw you
hey hey hey whoa whoa hi hi hey hey I'm
gonna go bro you want to go no god I'm
gonna lose this fight
i'ma lose the first fight again won't go
special my bottle upside your head
how's that not stopping you Biff ah it's
getting dark things are going dark
hammer Shoom wait don't tell me this has
the Gorn style of death like you have to
kill it before you pass out or something
for maybe I was just terrible I don't
know what just happened let's pretend
like that didn't happen boom I'm back
for round two baby you're gonna get face
full of me yeah yeah that's right you
get you stay down you want you want some
of this
hmm you want some ice oh good rest you
piece of garbage you piece of garbage
you piece of garbage I hate you there we
go okay this way this way - what this
way - what exactly okay that was easy
I could have hopped over I guess - oh
that's
that's odd don't know what that's all
about but okay hey you go you gonna be a
dick maybe I should just preemptively
gate you huh
nobody's hmm we don't know what that's
all about
nobody says in no one's a part of that
body word gonna go into you hello ah ah
nope not not happened really two hits
and you go down I punched you like 13
times in your gullet and you didn't you
didn't even flinch
oh hey something out there I see you can
I put you in my yeah I can okay Oh God
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] can him climb you
there was no point out there really hurt
alright whatever um so I don't know
what's going on that's peculiar up there
but whatever let's just keep going oh
that's probably not good does this do
just little ol me with little ol me with
a little cart little me with okay you
have no idea I'm here
oh god that's not tall enough to protect
me well this is peculiar alrighty then
oh boo this way oh that's not good
you're not dying no way I'm dying
yep I'm dying
ooh lucky notice all pat mark packages
are property of monoghan industries any
removal is theft have a nice day
well I kind of took everything and then
I got nothing but a whole lot of
something I got to get past these
turrets somehow maybe I can Captain
America this [ __ ] oh I bet I can
oh you will not get me you will not get
me you will not get me oh I'm a genius
I'm an evil genius open open says me
okay that opened and that did nothing
but I've got my shield and that's all I
need a there's something over there well
they're giving me a lot of ammo but I've
got nothing to do is because I didn't
grab my gun no no we don't you don't see
me you don't see me hello
oh oh hi your block yeah Frick the Frick
the Frick right I came for this yeah
Frick are you I'm really gonna yeah
Captain America in Avengers you in a
second but I just need this oh stop that
backwards Oh backwards backwards
backwards oh come on just get it there
we go
well you thought you were gonna give me
the answers that you were not yeah did
you know what all of you are
that's the headset thing god dammit if
you spill my drink I'm gonna kill you
yeah yeah okay okay okay Oh stress level
bone works
oh that's well that's odd okay well
there's been peculiar I guess I can go
up here here we go well zukes okay
gadzooks okay we're fine you oh my god
gadzooks
okay this is what the [ __ ] okay I'm up
I'm up I'm up get my stuff over there
and really go for it
well god damn it oh yeah dude okay I did
it
I'm the greatest there ever was I am
worthy you son of a [ __ ] I hate you
oh stop yeah no yeah get get get get you
got a button on the back I see how this
ah well never flip you god yeah bad wow
this world is driving me mad
oh you so if I was this what oh [ __ ] oh
okay
well I don't know if it's worth keeping
you boom boom boom boom oh that's
worthless okay now no one's gonna mess
with me then oh no dear I'm too volatile
too dangerous right now to be messed
with
so don't even try it it would not be
worth it I have a key I will shove it in
here there we go
let me who the Frick do you think you
are I don't have what I need anymore but
I'm at [ __ ] you in the ass God could you
I got you what are you you wanna mess
away you are you're nothing as I always
suspected you were hold on nothing what
are you up now quite up up high over
there it's over time behind wha what are
you doing what are you what are you
alright you do me what am I ready to you
and what are you to me what have I done
what is the point of this I don't care
hoping alright more like closed
oh yes that's it Oh emergency weapon
Locker though I'm Captain America I
don't need you let me in wherever that
is
get out of my way shove that in where
are you get out of way hi
that is weird I go this way though what
is that I don't care what are you what
are you I wish I could open you I don't
have any credits how do I get credits I
don't know I don't I have no idea how to
get credits I never was even able to get
credits in the first place huh whatever
he doesn't matter no credit for me I
don't need a gun guns are [ __ ]
anyway get out my bow it's me time down
of course down it push of course it goes
down where's my Captain America shield
oh [ __ ] oh my god the sprinting is
absurd I don't like the push button on
these things really not fun there okay
hi about a breadth-first god oh my god
oh my god I'm gonna bout oh [ __ ] I'm
gonna vomit oh my god I'm gonna father
but I gotta get through oh my god I
can't bring button just go forward
hey boy died Oh who can't see B I can't
see you you can't see me I am behind you
oh far above of it Paul you don't try oh
yeah don't you try where's your first
one that's us weapon Locker
yes weapons are though [ __ ] oh my god I
got a hit oh my god I gotta go to
Bobbitt oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
B oh [ __ ] I've never been more nauseous
in my life okay cool that's Bob works oh
my god I'm so sick don't let me be
nauseous little getting the wave don't
let that get in the way they gave the
game is good really is I was just taking
it really fast oh I guess okay I'm fine
it's all good because you know what this
is a great game I still have no idea
what the story is I was playing it for
like an hour over it or I still it opens
coolest tree I would love to keep going
but I can't good about it like I said
okay thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought in
the comments below if you wanna see more
bow works oh my god either
let me know in the comment like the
video subscribe Jesus Jesus please scoop
bail exists and as always I'll see you
[Music]
you